on s'en va à la conquête de new york du
marché de la ville de new york
sophie brochu est avec nous bonsoir
madame auch alors non seulement c'est
possible mais ça peut c'est votre projet
le plus important d'exportation
d'électricité depuis le contrat signé
entre le massachusetts
oui en fait c'est un projet qui est un
petit peu plus gros que celui du
massachusetts qui était déjà le contrôle
d'exportation le plus important
d'hydro-québec
je veux quand même rappeler à tout le
monde qu'on est dans le cadre d'un appel
d'offres on n'est pas seul à faire des
propositions à la ville de new york la
ville de new york mais notre processus
concurrentiel nous avons déposé
aujourd'hui comme nous l'avons annoncé
comme bien d'autres une proposition
alors à la conquête de new york que je
vous dirais oui mais pas à n'importe
quel prix
alors si on nous choisirons sera content
d'avoir été choisi une prix qu'on a
déposé
si d'aventuré quelqu'un est plus
concurrentiel que nous ayons ce propos
triste parce que à ces prix là on aurait
préféré garder notre électricité pour
l'heure c'est un processus
d'optimisation
c'est une conquête mais pas n'importe
quel prix c'est ça vous envoyer le
message qu'on veut pas bazarder notre
électricité à aux états unis a appris
que comme terre-neuve l'a fait il ya des
décennies
en fait il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
hydro québec va déjà new york sur le
marché de gros clin marchés boursiers
sur ce marché là on ne reconnaît pas la
caractéristique verte de l'électron
d'hydro-québec
new york le comptabilise mais on n'est
pas régulé riz au lait sur le marché de
l'eau alors lorsque l'on cherche à faire
c'est apprendre marché où on reconnaît
l'électron vers où on fait une entente
de gré à gré avec des gens qui sont
prêts à payer pour l'électron vert à
l'ars et c'est là que c'est doublement
intéressant pour nous 10 térawattheures
donc c'est à peu près l'équivalent le
disait de ce qui a été conclu et le
massachusetts est ce que ça voudrait
dire ajouter de la capacité de
production au québec où avec les surplus
on est correct non on n'a pas besoin de
construire les ouvrages additionnel pour
ces pays ce marché
on a les équipements qu'il faut entre la
puissance on à l'énergie qu'il faut pour
ça dans l'ensemble il faut comprendre
que hydro québec gère l'ensemble d'un
parc de production et jeanne ensemble de
tous ses engagements que ce soit au
québec ou à l'extérieur et prennent en
main on est en train d'optimiser les
capacités existantes et les capacités
qui peuvent éventuellement être mise en
place avec des énergies soupe agile
comme l'éolien le solaire qui par
ailleurs sont intermittents puis le
mexique que l'on peut faire nous au
québec est extraordinaire qui en dit
quoi et tu as peu près imbattable c'est
de mixer des énergies renouvelables au
sud de la frontière aussi impôts
seulement de ce côté ci avec nos
réservoirs hydroélectriques qui peuvent
assurer la fiabilité omettre son
ensemble et on a soumis en fait deux
compositions aujourd'hui année à une
première proposition 100%
l'hydroélectricité du québec mais aussi
une proposition qui inclut une énergie
renouvelable au sud de la frontière dans
l'état de new york où donc on aura une
combinaison hydroélectricité québécoise
avec énergie renouvelable ont sud de la
frontière
que ce soit au régulateur à décider ce
qui leur plaît plus et si ça
fonctionnait on parle quand même c'est
important pour new york là je lisais
c'est le cinquième de la delà de ce qu
delà de l'électricité consommée à new
york c'était beaucoup la wii écoutez si
vous voulez si vous voulez que frapper
l'imaginaire dans la réduction des gaz à
effet de serre dans les villes de l'oiac
c'est comme si on leur retire et 44 pour
cent de toutes les voitures de la ville
de nuit alors rappelez vous quand on
allait marcher là ya pas si longtemps
et puis tout à coup il y aurait presque
la moitié de moins de véhicules en
émissions de gaz à effet de serre cc
mans c'est un des plus grands projets de
décarbonation le massachusetts aussi est
très grand grand projet de décarbonation
et c'est un changement de paradigme très
fort dans la volonté politique de
décarbonés les économies et pour que
l'électron vert du québec sera ça prend
des liens
alors on a vu la carte pour new york que
rien ce serait un ce serait sous terre
au sud de notre frontière on voit le 545
km puis bon ça fera partie du contrat on
verra comment ça va évoluer mais là vous
avez signé que le massachusetts
et là vous avez des problèmes au maine
il ya des entreprises concurrentes
américaines d'hydro-québec comme cal
payne qui vous font une guerre qui
veulent pas que vous passiez là qui font
une guerre d'opinion publique et ironie
là le fonds de retraite canadiens
l'équivalent de la caisse des dépôts
canadien à des actions dans kal penn qui
font la guerre et dhr au québec vous
faites quoi devant ça va écouter d'abord
on classe quelques appels s'y trouve que
j'avais j'avais rejoint directement
l'ancien dirigeant du fonds de pension
canadiens qui vous souviendrez a
démissionné parce qu'elle est il se
faire vacciner en israël et ont changé
de direction alors on va reparler avec
la direction que je parle avec
l'ensemble de l'écosystème financier
canadien pour les sensibiliser au fait
qu' il le massachusetts à l'époque a
fait un grand appel d'offres ya eu plein
de propositions
hydro-québec au damier le projet est
allé chercher tous les permis requis
en trente trois mois deux franchi toutes
les aires réglementaire mais des gens
qui sont comme autant et des gens comme
kal penn qui produit de l'électricité à
partir d'énergies fossiles corps humain
hydro de l'arrivée d'hydro-québec
c'est la fin de leurs membres parce que
les années le solaire ils ne craignent
pas parce que ce sont des énergies
renouvelables et intermittents alors
qu'un hydro-québec la rive on est vert
on est prêts on dit concurrentiel qu'on
est là une temps alors ils ont là un
modèle d'affaires de la destinée dans
les bric dérive dans les mers du sud
yem passe à lyon de l'argent et pour eux
ce projet lors ils vont attaquer
l'électron vocaux les au massachusetts
et on est encore devant des tribunaux
ils ont des sous ils nous attaquent
partout ils attaquent les autorités du
maine qui nous ont donné
oui et je fais une petite nuance ici
avec new york parce qu'ils vont être là
pour nous pour se battre contre nous
montre la même logique mais en oubliant
le projet de transmission des déjà tous
ses permis lui on n'a pas ce problème là
nous y a mais je reviens à vos problèmes
un calepin le régime de pensions du
canada
quand vous dites que vous faites des
appels es qu'ils ont une emprise sur
cale pas parce qu'ils sont actionnaires
ce qu'ils ont une emprise pour dire ça
suffit lâche et donc et bien qu'un peu
moi je ne crois pas qu'ils n'ont pas
d'emprise et les fonds de pension qui
investissent défend et qui ont des
politiques je ne sois pas je ne pense
pas qu'il soit dirigiste
mais je ne peux pas croire un fonds de
pension canadien dans une compagnie
privée
parce que même eux khalfane elle est
privée que si c'était une compagnie
publique
je pense qu'ils auraient un petit job
mais là ils ont privatisé l'organisation
à l'intérieur d'un conseil
d'administration d'une compagnie privée
il ya des conversations qui peuvent
avoir recours et moi si j'étais sur le
board de canidés le punch une femme dont
de quelques amis je me poserai des
questions sur la nature de mon
investissement
donc encore une fois que quel point ils
s'inscrivent dans un processus
réglementaire qui tentent de faire
dérailler un processus réglementaire
c'est de bonne guerre car les cas le
permis est gagné je n'accepte pas qu'une
compagnie attaque un dimanche hydro
québec alors qu'elle est financée et je
pense que vous devez avoir votre
attention sur voie je pense que tu
investis ça se pourrait fournier parce
que ce qu'est née d'une pinte une femme
fait que je sais pas qui gère vos frères
vos plantations à radio canada mais ça
se crée alors les fonctionnaires
fédéraux dans l'homme dans leur fonds de
pension finances
une entreprise qui attaquent hydro
québec qui a respecté toutes les règles
visant posture c'est une énergie fossile
il n'aime pas l'énergie hydro québec
parce qu'elle est propre et les
concurrentiel
même pot c'est qu'hydro-québec
conditions pour les grands pour on est
pointée en plein on n'ira pas dans un
jusqu'auboutisme déraisonnable mais qui
nous attaquent ils ont trouvé chaussure
à leur pied on va se défendre mon sens
cela vous êtes comme quand vous avez dit
la semaine dernière ma patience à rivas
admettre le sens là avez-vous des
recours au delà de con de dire
publiquement que mettre la pression sur
le régime de pensions du canada
avez-vous des recours oui en fait on
peut parler avec les régimes de pension
peux pas j'ai parlé avec le ministre la
ministre fédérale des finances qui est
utilement et cette classe lisse ou aux
états unis on se bat aux points
pourquoi penser qu'on est tout seul on a
on a des appuis politiques
on a des appuis réglementaire écouter
ils nous attaquent nos pays on est avec
l'avocat du monde présentement parce que
kal penn indirectement à travers un
groupe cello environnemental nous
attaquent avec leur aide à ces gens là
ils n'ont ils n'ont pas de pudeur et il
tenait il ya des politiciens qui
enfourche un cheval parce que parce que
ils veulent se faire une carrière qui
tiennent des propos qui sont ils sont
qui sont franchement facétieux et je
vous dirai en eux vu dans les dernières
années aux états unis déjà qu'ils ont
perdus et qu'ils ont dit je n'ai pas
peur je ne vous avais perdu et les gens
qui ont perdu parfois n'accepte pas de
perdre
enfin jusqu'au bruxisme on est en terre
américaine est sélectionné c'est con
pour jouer il faut jouer la game
américain dont on a un reportage sur
après la pause sur notre chambre qui
accorde ans après sur le parti
républicain mais est ce que monsieur
lago et quand est ce que tout le monde
est sensibilisé vous avez fait par là
tout le monde est ce que le monde
politique est sensibilisée à tout ça
depuis sur la question du fonds par
s'organiser de plus en plus d'accords et
comme je le disais nous dit moi je je je
hydro québec c'est une maison élégante
elle ne fait pas les choses comme ceux
comme je le fais présentement mais du
côté américain les gens ont des
approches extrêmement difficile
extrêmement du extrêmement agressif
alors ce n'est pas agressif du tout ce
que je fais j'ai juste dit déterminé je
suis vous avez été choqué la semaine
dernière puisque les députés vous ont
posé des questions sur votre salaire non
pas le salaire d'hydro-québec qui connut
son âge 37 500 quelques mails dans che
était mais vous avez gardé votre siège
de la b1 bmo conseil d'administration
pour plus de 200000 se faisait
renoncerai pas vous êtes j'ai le droit
je vois continuer même si ça peut donner
l'impression que je donne pas tout mon
temps à hydro québec
écoutez ici je faisais si je vais y
attelons puis tu as fait deux semaines
je faisais du katla est pour personne
que c'est sûr j'aurais de saut alors si
j'ai étudié un dossier de conseil
d'administration de la fatigue puisque
je fais ce sont bons tant fonctionnel
alors qu'on roule des chemins de fer des
deux cent quinze heures pour hydro
québec mais moi je suis absolument pas
gêné de ça je suis complètement investi
avec hydro-québec et franchement je
cherche la charge de détonations émotive
avec cette affaire je la comprends pas
depuis que je me suis choquée la semaine
dernière c'est pas parce qu'on parlait
de ça parce qu'on connaît du pain où on
avait deux ans pour parler des dossiers
énergétiques
il ya un an quelques députés de
l'opposition qui se sont servis de 52
une plateforme politique ouvre à ce jeu
c'est pourquoi on a perdu une heure sur
deux pour parler de ma rémunération
voulu parler de ma rémunération je le
dis on va prendre on va aller prendre
une bière au près d'une station de radio
des shows de boucane que les gens
veulent pas
on avait deux heures pour parler de
dossiers comme celui là pour
sensibiliser une population pour que le
québec politiques syndicaux depuis dix
jours à aline en vélo on ne fait ça
comme peau de chagrin de leur choix moi
ce qui me plaît c'est pour une
commission comme ça monsieur voix c'est
vrai pour toutes les sociétés des deux
passes on se prépare pendant des
semaines des équipes de direction se
prépare il désire partout dans
l'organisation qui manque de goût et fin
et on arrive là et ça fait pouet
ouais c'est ça qui me choque on n'a pas
besoin d'être soucier troc reçu le temps
pour se parler des dossiers sans jamais
si on vous avait dit avant d'accepter
vous run vous devez renoncer à ce
conseil d'admistration là dans une
banque vous auriez pas pris l'emploi
j'imagine un nom avec cet épisode et
c'était convenu d'avancé
le gip qu'est ce qui se passe là je dis
magique c'est parce qu'on s'en allait
bientôt en et les sciences
parce que c'était le cas quand j'ai pris
ma fonction je fragilité renouveler dans
la fonction ça faisait partie de mes
conditions édictées savons faire plaisir
dans les mettre l'épaule à la roue
d'hydro-québec et comme un minimum pour
moi c'est important la banque
j'ai contribué je contribue est ce que
je vis la fête de moins bien meilleur
dirigeant
je pourrais vous donner plein désert
mais l'on ne peut vous êtes vous que
j'ai défoncé après tout le reste des
missions mais à la branche sorte qu'on
pourra pas vous reprocher ne pas dire
clairement ce que vous pensez des choses
qu'on va suivre ce contrôle à projette
contre avec new york avec l'intérêt
merci beaucoup merci à vous aussi vous
intéresser m